bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur arte france quelle est votre
réaction face à cette décision du
conseil d'état
bonsoir alors ma réaction par rapport à
cette décision est simple c'est que
manifestement cette décision reconnaît
que le droit la religion on inclut la
possibilité de participer collectivement
effectivement à des manifestations
religieuses
par contre le conseil d'état estime que
les conditions ne sont pas remplies
donc comme la mosquée de paris l'a
indiqué par le biais de son recteur qui
est aussi avocat le cadre de cette
demande a été faite puisque à partir du
19 mai hymne à la réouverture des
terrasses et un plan de déconfinement ça
n'a pas été fait au plein boom de la
crise sanitaire ça a été fait parce que
on estimait que d'une part les
conditions sanitaires peut-être l'aurait
permis et d'autres pas kylie a
effectivement entre la nuit du 8 au 9
mai la nuit du destin qui est importante
pour la communauté musulmane est donc
l'occasion était rêvée pour la mosquée
de paris et de pouvoir voir si oui ou
non finalement une exception étaient
envisageables manifestement ce n'est pas
le cas et effectivement la mosquée de
paris en prend acte avec avec
satisfaction est là pour çà d'état
justifie sa décision par la situation
sanitaire à préoccupante c'est un
argument vous entendez c'est un argument
qui qu'il faut entendre en réalité comme
je n'ai indiqué il y avait certes un
facteur qui pouvait laisser penser que
dérogation était envisageable
ce n'est pas le cas la communauté
musulmane ne demande pas avoir un
traitement différencié du reste de la
population si les indicateurs ne le
permettent pas on en prend acte
tous et il n'y a pas d'autre possibilité
maintenant on espère que effectivement
les chiffres permettront dans les
prochaines semaines à ce que le plan de
déconfinement qui est proposée par le
gouvernement puisse se réaliser dans de
bonnes conditions
voilà tout simplement alors le juge des
référés a rappelé qu'il était déjà
possible pour les musulmans de
participer collectivement aux cérémonies
religieuses organisées entre 6 heures et
19 heures et que le ministre de
l'intérieur
à pour la période du ramadan autorisé
l'ouverture des mosquées dès la première
prière du matin avant 6 heures ce qui
marque la fin du couvre-feu
il ya déjà eu quelques allègements du
côté de l'intérieur pour permettre aux
musulmans se retrouver absolument il ya
eu quelques allègements on s'en
satisfait maintenant il y avait la
demande qui avait été formulée pour des
prières de nuit c'est à dire que les
prières 1h30 ou 2h après après la tombée
de la nuit
ça a été refusé depuis le début et les
préfectures sont fait le relais auprès
des différentes associations qui gèrent
les lieux de culte là c'est un événement
exceptionnel c'est à dire la nuit du
destin se déroule une seule fois par an
et au vu d'une part de cette baisse des
indicateurs et de ses possibles
déconfinement c'était envisagé
maintenant il est vrai que il y a tout
même la possibilité dans le cadre du
couvre-feu d'assister à la majorité des
prières et comme vous l'avez rappelé le
ministre 20 heures a permis à ce qu' il
ya un décalage très légers entre on va
dire la première prière qui s'étendait
au début du ramadan aux alentours de 5
heures et maintenant plus vers 5h30 jeu
juste avant le couvre-feu la fin du
couvre-feu qui est qui et à 6 heures
donc il ya quand même un certain nombre
de mesures et donc la communauté on est
tout de même satisfaite merci beaucoup
d'avoir pris le temps de réagir sur
notre antenne sami mme beaulac et avocat
au barreau de paris